اذا هي جوله تعزيز العلاقات وتطويرها في
اكبر اسواق السعوديه من الطيه اسيا كما
اسلفنا لكن الامر ليس متعلقا بالنفتفحسب
وانما بتوسيع التعاون فيما يتعلق بثلاسل
التوريد وبدائل النفط الخام في اندونيسيا
مثلا شركه ارامكو وشركه وبرتامينا
الاندونيسيه اعلنتاعه عن الخطط التعاون
عبر سلسله قيمه الهيدروجين والامونيا
النظيفين تجاريين تجاوز حجم التبادل بين
البلدين العام الماضي الخمسه مليار دولار
ونتحدث هنا عن مليارين و800 مليون دولار
الصادرات سعوديه الى اندونيسيا واكثر من
مليارين او 250 مليون للوالده من
اندونيسيا ارامكو وسابك شركه ثانيه
السعوديه
بعمل كبير في جاره اخرى كوريا الجنوبيه
السوق الحيويه للسعوديه في العقد الاخير
فقط تجاوز حجم التبادل التجاري 330 مليار
دولار كما يتشارك البلدان باكثر من 120
مشروعا الصناعيا وتجاريا واستثماريا وهناك
43 شركه كوريه تعمل على تنفيذ مشاريع كبرى
في السعوديه